leave your entries in us already crowd
no more fun and games no more sitting on
our asses
no more handing out poster tonight we
fight tonight we tell t-series we murder
TCP well why is it taking you so goddamn
long this whole team series suck me was
getting kind of old wait what was that
did you guys see that
well what's there what the Frick hello
and welcome everyone to long let's just
jump into it yesterday
last night before I went to sleep the
absolute man line you own my post head
up with set a Gatling gun what is that
is that a nine year old in the back you
see what I'm talking about
we're not handing out posters anymore
we're going at war we have Elon Musk
APEC's
hello how are you reply to mr. beets as
well a triple dog dare you to host meme
review five bucks I'll give you five
bucks and I'll buy a Tesla you drive a
hard bargain but okay Tesla is now the
official curve the mean community why
did you buy a Tesla oh you know as a
mean just as a meme petition for
Jablonski to say subscribe to PewDiePie
at the Oscar ceremony where's the
petition where is it god damn it
Jack Black the possibility of him saying
subscribe to beauty plant yes who's not
realizing he's wearing headphones wait
what what is she playing is she playing
[ __ ] lasagna you are wearing headphones
Felix being close to the
[Music]
oh look it's more people pointing out
that I'm an idiot what's it gonna be now
can't wait has own headphone design with
integrated mic clips on external hey
that's smart okay has a TV doesn't watch
the TV it takes effort to put a picture
up there has his own merch where's plain
white t-shirt well sometimes it's nice
to be simple okay has his own chair
design stands well I like standing okay
has his own sponsored energy drink
drinks Red Bull I don't drink red Bull
I was drinking flavored sparkling water
checkmate girl disrespectful to her
parents
doctor pill range what if I
go on dr. Phil and he examines me and he
sends me to the range
I could ranch vlogs smash like if you're
excited for range vlogs how it really
did just as I remembered it mark
Carey I mark actually carries a stool
with him anywhere he goes so anytime you
see him in any shot this is what it
actually looks like I'm going to link
all the creators I just mentioned now
they could be Nazis I haven't checked
please I like how that's an actual
disclaimer I have to put now on
ironically we I'm not supposed to share
my opinion by name a more iconic do you
can't you can't doc I feel like I'm
becoming a Normie what do you do when
you see a funny meme I smile and
scrolled by pensioned Branch send them
to the ranch oh my god oh my god what is
happening what they are kind of get back
hostile defensive reactions if you put
out a message that says what is this
engage I want to be involved I want to I
made my computer run 16 hours to get PT
Pais face on doctor panel this is the
result support me and are engaged with
what I do
oh my god volved in there that's amazing
[ __ ] lasagna on 20 different instrument
try to getting this on the wine but
still didn't get featured okay well I'm
watching it now so this best be good
but an audience by reddit terrific
audience get its that live stream Oh on
an actual oh okay Wow with a rocket are
really feeling cigar bugs either
[Music]
what the hell is that it's got a good
sound to that what it's called
oh damn he's actually good at it Oh all
at the same time No
yeah I've accidentally that's what okay
Felix s are very epic Thank You Felix
pace are you did it that's incredible
the mayonnaise was definitely my
favorite petition for pills to make a
Lego reveal at a hundred million that's
what I've saved that after all these
years leg reveal these World War two
bunkers are just incredible
Wow that's fascinating
Wow the reap wait what the real reason
why the sub gap Rose I called an entire
phone book for PewDiePie oh my god it's
below subscribe to his channel for me
well T what I'll have I'll have my uh my
associate follow up with you in a few
days here her name is Gloria Borger
thank you
what well that's why you need to
subscribe goddammit si a photo that's
great thank you very much for doing your
part incredible incredible job ha ha ha
ha
Brad one when he's editing his videos
and he has to add the code could we get
pewds to see that his own game hasn't
updated his sub count what this game is
irrelevant
this game is garvik Oh dairy pills that
make you stare at
certain Swedish man who never asked his
somebody in action
hey don't look at me like that okay you
guys did this I had nothing partaking in
it I used to ask you questions and all
you guys posted or memes so I thought
hey I'll just roll with it anyway then
they don't want they don't want requests
they just watch the post and it ain't my
fault and you can blame it on me as much
as you like petition for pewds to name
dr. Phil episodes child's review well
they're all gets zero so it wouldn't be
that interesting but no god it was Brad
all along only he can harness Shaggy's
true power
oh my god the power of shaggy how could
we have been so blind Brad is Shaggy and
scooby-doo scooby-dooby-doo this makes
me so excited how tall is Adolf Hitler
just hit 667 million subs probably the
last milestone to be first at reaching
that worship ft line a beautiful line a
beautiful leg petition to get a linen a
on dr. Phil so she can be sent to the
ranch please God please I will never ask
you for anything else just petition for
pews to play we've sport you guys are
spying on my set I actually laughed at a
Family Guy meme on ironically
congratulations to me I did it making a
normal me adding myself on the
background so I can get myself into what
no no the reason that shaggy meme hasn't
died yet is because he's gotten too he's
too powerful to be forgotten
god damn bright what have you done how
could you do this
that bucket get do these back back tella
Fred Fred yes it was back guess who's
damn it she was dead
yes I'm stuck get some stuff guess he
was dead
it came out of nowhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn back at it again alright if you
guys haven't subbed to sage it do it
right now incredible chalice honestly is
fire main fan out of bread so the
chances of this getting into the wire
has increased substage what built
pewdiepie in minecraft how is that even
possible
time-lapse here sir are za whoa holy oh
okay that's crazy
damn I think YouTube did a noob see oh
we were on trending I didn't even
realize that must have been a newbie I
guess YouTube realized PewDiePie the
n-word Brent head hitting that's not
true that's not true
oh my god how tall is Felix a scientific
study diameter of PT 5 headset is 11
point 2 by measuring the height say we
are enable we were able to calculate the
size of Felix head my head is twenty
seven point five centimeters calculated
by using proportion of headset to the
rest of his head once we had the size of
the head we calculate his overall height
calculated by using proportion of head
to the rest of the body
Felix height each equals roughly one
seventy seven point five centimeters of
God but wait
everybody knows that Felix doesn't have
legs and subscribe to PewDiePie next me
you heard it here first
subscribe to PewDiePie we have grandmas
on their side grandmas oh alright it's
my honey smashing like subscribe in this
video thank you guys for watching thanks
for all the memes
I love recording these videos I am so
proud of this community I'll see you
guys tomorrow
what's it gonna be double the Y double
the Y to Louise in a row that would be
crazy you want pyramids we got them oh
you're into casos huh we got you covered
baby you want some bets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit